بمعنى انك قررتي انك تنظري الى الصوره
الان كا بنظره مختلفه قرانا في احد المرات
انك اجبتي صحفي بانك ترغبي بالحديث عن
الحب وتسديد المغفره بدل الحديث عن نفسك
كضحيه هل توضحين لي اكثر عن ذلك
يستقبلها اولا بالغضب وانا واحده من هؤلاء
لم اكن اعرف في البدايه كيف اتعامل مع
الصوره كنت سجينه في سؤال لماذا انا
ولماذا استمر بالمعاناه لكن الان تصالحتم
مع تلك الصوره مع جسدي مثل ما هو لم تعد
بالنسبه لي صوره عن رعب الحرب القدر ما هي
سفيره سلام لم تعد تظهر البربريه لانني
اود ان اتحدث عن الحب ان اجسد المغفره لم
تعد تلك الصوره تتحدث عن الموت بل انها
تظهر الحياه تلك الصوره التي كانت في فتره
ما سبب ماساه هي التي تصل الان وتكتنقذني
من الالم كان بالرغم من كل كرهك للصوره
وعدم رغبتك بالنظر اليها وانك من البدايات
نظرتي اليها كانها صوره بشعه الا انها
كانت علامه فارغه يعني بعض الاحداث منها
صورتك ادت الى تغيير مسار المعركه على
الارض الفيتناميه وهذا وحده كافي بان يكون
مصدر فخر بالنسبه لك ادارتنا نقول ذلك
سؤال الاخير لو سمحت عانيت كثيرا في موضوع
العلاج والطب والعمليات واجريت لك عمليات
عديده وكثيره هل انتهينا من هذه المرحله
الان
هذا صحيح لكن العمليات لم تنتهي بعد وطريق
المعفاه على عكس طريق الالام ليس سهلا
فالالم كانت ترافقني في اغلب فترات حياتي
بثمانيه درجات من 10 لكيفيه لا يمكن
تحملها لكنني الان في وضع اشعر فيه بثلاث
الى اربع درجات من الالم من 10
للالم موجوده ولكنه هناك تحسنا لكن كل ذلك
علمني كيف اتحرر من ثقه للكراهيه وكيف اصل
الى السلام كلما ايقظني الغضب او صممتني
المراره على امل ان اصحو يوما ما دون الم
باذن الله ونحن نتمنى لك ذلك ايضا شكرا
جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا سيده فان في
كيم بوك